et donc à l'âge de 89 ans frédéric back
qui est un des plus grands cinéastes
d'animation de l'histoire gagnant de
deux oscars on se rappellera notamment
de l'homme qui plantait des arbres red
back était aussi un militant de la
nature et de sa protection
bertrand elle nous rappelle la vie de ce
véritable monument québécois salut
québec et thank you very much to you il
n'a pas gagné un oscar
il en a gagné deux ce qu'il appelait
humblement ces petits dessins ont fait
de frédéric back
un des plus grands cinéastes d'animation
au monde
frédéric back grandi en france où il
étudie la musique et les beaux-arts
à 24 ans il arrive à montréal rencontre
ghislaine qu'il épouse
il ne repartira plus lyrique bac bac va
faire toute sa carrière à radio canada
dans les années 50 il dessine en direct
à la télévision
il crée des décors d'émissions pour
enfants les maquettes de la série
iberville innove en créant cet oiseau de
feu sur la musique de stravinsky et très
vite il se tourne vers le dessin
d'animation
pour fil des ans la technologie évolue
son style s'affirme
abracadabra illusion tout rien ses
créations sont vus dans de nombreux pays
début 80 crack devenu un succès
planétaire à travers l'histoire d'une
chaise berçante bac résume toute
l'histoire du québec
il remporte son premier oscar j'essaie
de d'un possible de de servir la beauté
de servir la vie je lui dis que dans 30
ans
ces 10000 chaîne serait magnifique la
nature sa beauté sa défense ou s'ils
sont les fondements de l'homme qui
plantait des arbres ce texte de jean
giono n'arrive par philippe noiret ses
vingt mille des 5,50 travail
une oeuvre colossale et en 2d toscane on
ne peut pas imposer un changement par la
violence alors j'essaie de faire le
mieux possible par des images
des images de plus en plus belles d'un
cinéaste militant et engagé le fleuve
aux grandes eaux est non seulement une
île où ça laurent et ses riverains
c'est un combat pour le protéger à 12tu
d'empoisonnement acceptable c'est cette
une
c'est une ignominie il faut cesser
absolument de polluer le fleuve tout
arrêter de laisser la chance de guérir
toute sa vie frédéric back a su montrer
enseigner partager son amour de l'art et
de la nature tout particulièrement
auprès des enfants faire en 2011
le prestigieux musée d'art contemporain
de tokyo présente la plus grande
rétrospective de son oeuvre au monde
un seul autre cinéaste d'animation a eu
droit au même honneur
walt disney mais je m'attendais pas à
quelque chose d'aussi délirant un besoin
immense immense et pourtant un mot qui
va très bien fait de red back immense
dans l'expression de la beauté de l'art
immense dans son implication sociale
même sa légendaire humilité du caïman si
frédéric back était enfin d'un créateur
c'est un homme aidé mon infinie de 1re
année de pertes radiographie envers les
plus grosses qui soit possible voilà
pour l'homme et donc ils sont